el arresto del obispo nicaragüense de
rolando álvarez es el capítulo más
reciente de la persecución del régimen
de daniel ortega contra la iglesia
católica quien ha tildado de golpistas y
terroristas a los religiosos estas
tensiones comenzaron en el mes de abril
de 2018 cuando estallaron las protestas
originadas por unas controvertidas
reformas a la seguridad social y que
fueron calificadas como un intento de
golpe de estado por parte de ortega la
policía nacional y civiles encapuchados
y armados afines al sandinismo
neutralizaron estas manifestaciones
antigubernamentales dejando al menos 328
muertos esto según la cdh álvarez el
obispo de la diócesis de matagalpa es
acusado de intentar organizar grupos de
violentos supuestamente con el propósito
de desestabilizar al estado de nicaragua
y atacar las autoridades
constitucionales saludamos entonces a
nuestra segunda invitada del día ella es
vilma núñez directora del centro
nicaragüense de derechos humanos el cnh
gracias a vilma por estar con nosotros
en directo américa de francés 24 y le
pregunto la situación actual de la
iglesia católica en nicaragua y porque
el gobierno se empeña en esta fuerte
persecución contra los religiosos
si muchas gracias la situación de las
ciencias católicas del pueblo de
nicaragua en general externa de la mente
crítica la situación la escalada
represiva que el gobierno ha venido poco
a poco impulsando se mantiene y crecen
cada día en este momento ya tenemos
prácticamente el
mismo
rolando álvarez
eso se llama
en la
videncia de sus padres con un operativo
militar que no vea a hacer cáncer verdad
está nada bien alma ya son 11
prácticamente los sacerdotes y
personas cercanas a la iglesia que se
encuentran prácticamente en el chipote
en una situación de indefinición
jurídica
13 cerdo te están ya dos condenados el
condenado y uno que no se sabe qué hacer
con él el padre de mulukukú y los ocho
acompañantes de monseñor álvarez que
fueron sustraídos violentamente en la
madrugada del viernes de la diócesis de
más balanza se encuentra en el tipo
state no se sabe qué es lo que quiere
escoger yo nosotros consideramos que
tienen en el a
en la cárcel a estas personas en el
cipote en el centro de tortura a estos
acompañantes del consell york para
buscar como precio darlo a él para que
acepten las propuestas que supuestamente
le podrían estar haciendo
en este caso las personas que están
dicen tratando de encontrar una salida
una salida que una salida de con señor
de nicaragua o una salida a la crisis
desde que existen verdad en el taller el
pueblo de nicaragua están
angustiados ésta al senado no vemos
ninguna señal de que haya por ejemplo lo
último que ha ocurrido en el por fin
pronunciamiento del papá ayer domingo
fer y este
pero no había ninguna ninguna reacción
no se conoce que esta gente llama al
papa haya encontrado eco aquí en la
actualidad incluso
sentimos el día ayer domingo como un
silencio un silencio expectante que hay
detrás de esta propia venta hay algo
concreto hay alguna salida que
signifique una verdadera solución una
solución que pasa por establecer las
condiciones para que existen también que
ese diálogo que el papá presenta aquí no
puede dialogar con las casas de llena
claro le preguntó entonces qué tan
influyente es la iglesia católica en
nicaragua y le pregunto también si por
esta influencia que pudiera tener la
iglesia católica es que el gobierno es
el régimen de daniel ortega se empeña en
perseguir a los líderes religiosos
claro
campos creíble como influencia y con
arraigo en la conciencia en el sentir de
la populación del 90% de la población me
cagüen de lo tiene en la iglesia y está
después el gobierno dictatorial de
daniel ortega rosario murillo a
prácticamente silenciado y eliminado
cualquier voz cualquier forma de
protesta límite y de reclamo quiere
prácticamente terminar con el pasión que
mantiene en este momento en la
conciencia y el de la gente
a su vez la decisión de que tienen que
luchar por sus derechos en la iglesia no
hay o más que hacer uso de su misión
evangelizadora dentro de su liturgia
dentro de sus actividades pastorales que
son verdaderamente coincidentes con la
lucha por los derechos humanos la
evangelización y las luchas pastorales
no son cuestiones abstractas gente
elevan al cielo precisamente tienen que
tener esta influencia en la evidencia y
en los problemas de la gente la tierra
bill me hablabas de un posible diálogo
este diálogo se pudiera se pudiera dar y
cuáles son las partes involucradas
si precisamente eso es lo que no se sabe
ayer el papa en su aparición dominical
por fin por fin decimos
[Música]
bien éste está demandando esa reacción
del papá éste por fin más manifestó
preocupación manifestó dolor
pero prácticamente una cura un llamado
hacia atrás cuando
señalan y cuáles son las causas o cuál
es la situación de crisis de ventas que
está viendo sólo digo que afecta a
personas ya y hay instituciones y dijo y
es que espera las posibilidades que haya
un diálogo franco y directo
cuál es ese diálogo franco y directo es
mejor que nadie conoce prácticamente la
actitud gubernamental altitud y tutorial
que prácticamente usaba
instrumentos necesarios y legítimos para
ganar tiempo y hagan inglés ya misma
aprenden del claro de su representante y
fue víctima de burlas tristes puede
decir de esta naturaleza y después de
eso qué
es
lo que el centro de esta de esta
negociación de esta de este diálogo es
definitivamente esto tiene que tratar el
diálogo tiene que ser prendida mente con
las partes por la bici con él
el régimen dictatorial pero las víctimas
tienen que saber no se puede negociar a
espaldas de una víctima su derecho no se
puede de ninguna manera ser vivir a
espaldas de un señor y al pagar su
decisión de seguir en nicaragua que lo
que él quiere y él reclama como su
derecho decidimos permanecer en el país
que lo vio nacer después de una manera
encontrarse una solución
ante problemas apagar calmar el juego
calmar las preocupaciones
sacrificando los derechos humanos de la
gente específicamente en este caso de
monseñor este éxito se nosotros creo que
demandamos en que es definitivamente que
la sentencia por favor frío contribuye a
violar le un derecho humano a monseñor
claro hombres y obligándoles
prácticamente definitivamente sería un
derecho humano más y los claros ha
parado el diálogo y los derechos humanos
no son citan